moi ce que je voudrais dire à Béni chose
c'est que je suis pas de ceux qui disent
que la police n'a pas besoin d'être
réformée il y a certainement besoin
d'une réforme pour améliorer
l'organisation le fonctionnement et pour
améliorer le traitement des criminalités
quotidiennes simplement les échos dont
on peut faire état quand on est
magistrat c'est que en réalité je pense
qu'on est dans une situation de crise
aujourd'hui puisque il faut bien
comprendre que la police ne se réduit
pas à la police aux effectifs de police
en tenue bleu sur la voie publique et
que il faut bien comprendre que si les
interpellations en fait par les
policiers ne sont pas suivis de par des
investigations de police complète et
impartiale et bien la justice qui fit ne
peut pas être de qualité la police
judiciaire c'est la police de la preuve
et il est donc indispensable que les
investigations qui soient diligentes
soient complètes soit exhaustive soit
impartial et que la procédure soit de
bonne qualité or on vit actuellement une
époque d'une situation de crise qui est
due à plusieurs facteurs il y a d'abord
une désinfection pour un poly judiciaire
et pour l'investigation
qui se traduit par un déficit de
vocation et d'attractivité et par suite
de sous-effectif il suffit de lire le
rapport on se rend compte qu'à 17000 OPJ
alors qu'il en faudrait 22000 il en faut
donc davantage mais c'est comme les
médecins il faut pas non plus baisser la
qualité de la formation il faut qu'il
soit toujours aussi bien formé la
complexité de la procédure pénale j'en
dirai pas plus là-dessus à la commission
des Lois du Sénat qui c'est ça aussi
bien systémieux que moi la réforme des
corps et carrières de la police
nationale de 1995 qui dans les services
de sécurité publique a vu un
désengagement majeur du judiciaire des
commissaires et de l'encadrement
supérieur des stocks de procédure en
souffrance dans les commissariats qui
s'aggravent constamment les dernières
estimations font état de 2 millions de
procédures en souffrance dans non traité
c'est fait quand même beaucoup sur un
volume de 5 millions 9 c'est quasiment
entière et qui seront donc pour la
plupart très vraisemblablement classés
contrairement au travail qui a été
préconisé par le ministère auprès des
parquets dans cette circulaire de
2021 donc ce sont là aussi autant de
victimes qui ont déposé plainte qui ne
recevons vraisemblablement jamais de
réponse des délais de traitement qui de
traitement d'enquête qui s'allonge et
enfin tous les magistrats font ce
constat le constat d'une dégradation
constante de la qualité des procédures
pénales particulièrement sécurité
publique dégradation qui tient autant à
l'insuffisance effective qu'elle
insuffisance qualité procédurale des
enquêteurs de la sécurité publique alors
même qu'ils assurent plus de 90% des
missions d'investigation